it's the zombie apocalypse there's
flesh-eating monsters roaming the
streets and you can only choose one
companion to help you survive who do you
pick the bodybuilder the power lifter
the martial artist the free runner or
the crossfitter I'll put it another way
would you rather have Arnie Bruce Lee
sebastien foucan Ronnie Coleman
rich Froning or someone else on your
side maybe Albert Einstein maybe it's
all about the brains in other words what
kind of training is the most effective
helping you to survive a hypothetical
zombie apocalypse I just want to point
out before we get started that this is
all my opinion it's supposed to be a
little bit of fun of course that's going
to cause some ire if I say that your
training methods isn't as useful to
someone elses for surviving the zombie
apocalypse but keep in mind this is just
one scenario and if you watch through to
the end you'll see why actually every
kind of training is super valuable
there's lots of very awesome reasons to
train but I think that one of the
coolest reasons is in order to be ready
for anything I like to think that if
ever there was a alien invasion I think
alien invasions are cooler than zombie
apocalypse this is but I thought that
zombie apocalypse had more punch for the
headline of this video but either way
either there's an alien invasion or a
zombie apocalypse and it's not going to
matter how rich you are or your status
or what job you've got or your
popularity all that matters is how well
you've been training how strong you are
how fast you are and that's when you can
step up to the plate and save the day
and you're the hero and everyone cheers
for you and that's normally about when I
wake up put obviously some forms of
training gonna be better than others for
surviving this situation this scenario
so that'll be fun to take a look at the
different training modalities and ask
which would be the most useful in a
scenario like this and if it sounds
ridiculous then bear in mind that this
is a mental exercise that both the CDC
and the Department of Defense in the
u.s. use in order to test whether or not
they're ready for anything so this is
quite a cool kind of litmus test for
your general ability to perform in a
crisis and presumably if you're good at
surviving a zombie apocalypse and you
could also be good at surviving another
more boring real-world scenario
like maybe you're in hostage situation
which is neither that realistic or
boring you know what I mean my prayers
the finally been answered and prayed for
a hostage situation yes they did every
single day there is actually a
difference between training and
exercising so a lot of people exercise
they workout whereas that's not quite
the same as training so in exercise or
working out it's all about that session
that training session you are trying to
burn calories build muscle break down
muscle it's all about the here and now
it's a kind of health maintenance or
maybe you're working towards some kind
of goal but on the whole it's about what
you can do in that session on the other
hand training is normally the reserve of
athletes or you know military personnel
and the idea here is that you're working
towards a set goal normally within a
specific domain so you're trying to get
faster for a race so you trying to get
stronger for a powerlifting competition
and now it's not so much about the here
and now it's not about killing yourself
in each and every workout instead it's
about building yourself up towards that
end goal that end date and building that
specific type of strength and
performance so you might have a period
ice training program this would include
things like rest days and it would build
up and it would mix things up in order
to keep your body you know surprised and
guessing but also building upon each
last session in order to gradually
improve in a specific domain so training
and exercise in that regard are quite
different but I don't wanna exercise I
want to train training is what Gopi does
and so obviously that's what I want to
do you don't hear Batman saying I'm
going to do my exercises now so if we're
not athletes and we're not training for
a specific event how can what we do be
called training well it is somewhat
related to another concept called
general physical preparedness and
general physical preparedness basically
refers to the kind of additional
training that someone who is training
for an event would do so Lois Simmons of
Westside barbell describes it as a and
paraphrasing a modicum of fitness that
is useful for absolute strength so in
other words you might be a power lifter
your aim might be to lift as much weight
as possible but you need some cardio
fitness you need some muscle endurance
you probably want some flexibility you
need to look after your general health
so another
you can't be so specified in your
training that you ignore everything else
because otherwise I mean you're lacking
the foundation the pillars of fitness
that will allow you to excel in a
specific area at the same time an
athlete who's training for you know golf
or football or sprinting is also going
to do other types of training on top in
order to ensure that they all round
healthy as well as being greater that
one specific thing so in theory what if
we took the idea of general physical
preparedness and made that the goal of
our trainings that we're training to be
as prepared as possible for anything I
call this sometimes general preparedness
training or ready for anything training
and in this scenario we're training for
a hypothetical situation which is a
zombie apocalypse and I'd argue that
that's kind of what a lot of people do
in these days people are training with
their functional exercises who are
training with mobility gymnastic
strength they're not trying to just look
good they're not just trying to build
calories they're trying to support their
body prevent injury and prove their 1
rep max is keep hitting pb's these
aren't physical professionals you know
they're not athletes but a lot of us now
are not just interested in training to
look better or to maintain our health we
want to be our best even though there's
no end point in mind so with all that
out of the way what would be the best
training modality well the obvious thing
to pick would be everything why pick at
all why not be a jack-of-all-trades
we're not trained as a long-distance
running sprinting track or power
building martial artist well there's a
few good reasons the first is that most
of us don't have enough time in the week
to do all those different types of
training especially as most of us also
need to have wives outside of it and
maintaining your general health is also
important you need recovery as I talked
about in my recent video at the same
time there's something called the
interference principle and the
interference principle means that when
you get really good in one domain it can
actually end up interfering with others
meaning that it's impossible to be a top
level athlete who is both a sprinter and
a long-distance runner you can be very
good at both which might be the best
strategy here we'll get into that more
but you can't be the best of both
because long-distance running and short
distance running required different
different biology one is slow-twitch
muscle fiber one is fast twitch muscle
fiber so if you're gonna train to build
one up more than you're removing your
capacity in the other area in fact this
issue is true to such an extent that
swimmers have been shown in one study to
have a lower jumping height than the
average person even though they've got
powerful and well-developed leg muscles
because they've trained to use them in a
different way they've learned different
movement patterns and they've built them
in different ways so actually the fact
that they're so good at swimming is
interfering with their ability to jump
even though they have better leg muscles
so swimmers are screwed come there
zombie apocolypse they'll be right in a
water world scenario but for zombie
apocalypse situations were in trouble
and this is then why something like
CrossFit needs to be taken and looked at
under the microscope because in theory
CrossFit's a cool idea for being
generally prepared ready for anything
but you're gonna have some interference
principles so these guys are going to be
great across the board but they're not
gonna be the best at any one specific
skill and the question is whether the
skills they've chosen are interfering
with each other or not whether they've
chosen good skills to train all at the
same time obviously some kinds of
training don't interfere with each other
so if you train your grip strength
that's not going to interfere with you
being a long-distance runner they're too
far removed likewise as we've seen with
general physical preparedness some types
of training actually complement each
other so training your brain isn't gonna
hurt your martial arts it's going to
improve it the skill that arguably
you're gonna need the most and a lot of
people agree rule number one of
Zombieland
is cardio or running the ability to run
away and that's true of zombie
apocalypses alien apocalypses and also
just being motor the best thing you can
do is to run away as long as you're not
leaving your wife and children with the
attackers rule number one for surviving
zombie land cardio
normally running way is the best
strategy so cardio is good because you
can keep running you can keep going and
not tire out and that's also really
important for a fight that's why Bruce
Lee said cardio is so important and any
boxer you'll just watch a boxing match
and you'll see how important cardio is
that's why they'll hug each other in
lying on top of each other at the end at
the same time though you also need to be
fast and quick you need to be able to
run away from a group that's surrounding
you especially if these are 28 days
later style faster zombies it's not
enough to just jog away you need to be
able to sprint fast to get out of danger
as soon as possible around exploding
buildings and other hazards that you're
gonna face during the apocalypse so that
means that it might make sense to train
with high-intensity interval training so
you're combining steady-state cardio
with bouts of intensity high-intensity
and the best way to do this I would
argue is with fartlek training which
I've discussed before it's got a stupid
name violette training means time place
so you're running and just alternating
between fast and slow exercise you know
high exertion light recovery during your
training if it's not necessarily a set
modality for that I would say aim to run
four miles a day roughly or a bit
further or a bit less whatever sync to
you and then try and speed up how
quickly you can do that by gradually
moving the ratio more towards the
sprinting and less towards the cardio
when it comes to escaping it's also very
important that you be able to climb and
jump that's why I mentioned sebastien
foucan
I think parkour would be incredibly
useful in this situation I actually
think that the martial application of
parkour and freerunning is something
that doesn't get discussed enough but if
you are being chased and you can jump
over something or onto something then
you've immediately captured the high
ground and that's a very good strategy
the reason for this is that if you're on
top of something and you're being chased
then those zombies even if they're good
climbers are gonna have to climb that
thing to follow you and you can kick
them off likewise if you jumped over
something
I have the high ground yet doing some
parkour some free rain would be great
that also means incorporate
incorporating things like pull-ups and
other bodyweight exercises into your
training climbing and bill during would
be really awesome that builds the grip
strength as well which we've already
said you know in previous videos is
important for building your strength and
it's not going to add a mass or anything
any size or slowed you down so at the
moment we've got someone doing
high-intensity interval training in
parkour that's a great combination for
getting away you can run across the
rooftops jump long distances stay out of
sight lay low but having some strength
is gonna be important as well not only
for fighting the zombies if they catch
up to you but also for fighting your
fellow man because we as we all know
from watching these films they are often
the biggest threat when you're fighting
for resources or when one of you is
actually secretly working for the big
organization that caused this whole mess
so having some strength is important and
I think our objective here is to build
as much strength as possible
without slowing ourselves down because
unfortunately big bulky muscle although
I've said in the past doesn't slow you
down as such it isn't energy efficient
it's not gonna help with running long
distances so I'm not saying it's bad but
ideally we want to build as much of a
good strength to weight ratio as
possible so we want to build as much
strength as possible without packing on
more size than necessary so that we can
stay light and nimble mobility will also
be important so we'll keep stretching so
what kind of training would be good for
this well I think calisthenics is
actually the most functional type of
training I've talked about this before
if you want to build to the kind of
strength that's useful in the real world
go for calisthenics if you've tried to
do something like a plant push-up you
will know that that incorporates your
entire body all these supporting muscles
incredible body control balance and all
these things and it's highly adaptable
because the thing about your body is
you're gonna be in a slightly different
position every time I've always said the
climbing trees is one of the most
functional things you can do because
every tree is different every branch is
a different width when you're running
and climbing and jumping and lifting
heavy things off the ground to use as a
weapon it's not going to always be with
the perfect technique it's not always
gonna be an ideal size it's not always
gonna be a barbell unless they are being
invaded in the gym which will be awesome
but that won't always happen so you need
to make sure that you're adaptable and
you can respond to any situation or
scenario and I think that bodyweight
training is one of the
ways to do that and that'll keep you
light as possible what's allowing you to
build as much strength and power as you
can and at the same time I think we
should do lots of explosive plyometrics
so that we're explosive so with fast and
can jump high punch hard and get away
and that's what's really gonna be useful
I would also combine this with some
traditional strength training weight
training being strong also has its
advantages as long as you don't get too
bulky in order to become heavy or to
consume too much energy muscle isn't
energy efficient although as I said
previously in another video it didn't
actually slow you down as such so good
forms of training for that would include
compound movements with big heavy
weights overcoming lights and metrics
you can build muscle fiber recruitment
without having too much bulk I would say
also you could combine this with just a
little bit of bodybuilding style
training because this is actually very
good for muscle endurance and that
allows you to exert strength over an
extended period of time and also adding
a little bit of muscle can acts as kind
of plating and if you do this then
you'll be able to carry the heavy
artillery or lift debris off of your
trapped comrades etc of course martial
arts gonna be really useful and anyone
who tells you that martial arts don't
make you a better fighter doesn't know
what they're talking about if you've
ever been in a fight with Sony doesn't
they martial arts they punch like this
with large arcing movements no power big
hooks and they kick by just flailing
their legs at you that you can then
catch martial arts turns your movements
into far more honed and practiced and
lethal blows that make a huge difference
in a fight and like I say it's not only
about fighting the zombies it's also
about fighting your evil comrades that
you're trapped in the bunker with which
martial art is the best for survival
well I'm not going to get into that that
is opening Pandora's box however I think
most people would agree that combining a
striking martial art and a grappling
martial art is a very good place to
start but actually I would argue that
the person who would be most useful who
I didn't include that the start there
that was a little bit of a trick the
person would be most useful in a real
zombie apocalypse scenario would be a
member of the Special Forces song with
actual Special Forces training and
that's not only because they are
actually trained in you know combat and
firearms training of course that's all
rather important my scenario you don't
have a gun but they also exposed to
these kinds of dangerous situations all
the time and that makes a huge
difference a lot of this is gonna be
mental you don't want to go to pieces in
the zombie apocalypse because that's not
going to help anybody and that normally
happens to at least one character and it
never ends well for them so you need to
be able to stay calm and collected in a
desperate situation and the best way you
can do that is probably with meditation
and perhaps with CBT I'll talk about
that more as I've said before but
meditation helps you to focus on what's
important what matters rather than being
distracted by the anxious thoughts that
aren't actually helping you out in this
scenario and exposing yourself to her
stress situations will also help I
talked in my video on flow States in
part two or maybe that's part one watch
them both I talked in that about how the
top performers especially in the Special
Forces had a metronomic heart rate and
ability to become more aroused and alert
whilst they were in a dangerous
situation but also to be more calm and
relaxed in between so that they could
then recover do the things that needed
to be done and then become more roused
again when it was time to go and fight
so and they also won actually as anxious
during this and partly that was
potentially due to the production of
DHEA which helped to keep them karma
even though their heart rate was aroused
studies show that DHEA suppresses the
activity of cortisol in the hippocampus
and other key brain area so it means
that you can be aroused like alert
psyched up but not psyched out and
that's how you need to be in this kind
of scenario like I say meditation is one
of the best things you can actually use
to improve that at the same time putting
yourself in awkward situations where you
normally get stressed and reminding
yourself to breathe focus and not get
too stressed out being mentally sharp
and focused and alert is important
getting lots of sleep will help with
this so - well eating the right diet
adding nootropics perhaps but at the
same time studies show and this is the
kind of firearms trading that you can do
studies show that playing computer games
actually increases your decision-making
accuracy without slowing it down
sorry increases you and
your decision-making speed without
harming your accuracy so in other words
people who play computer games
particularly shooting games and
especially at a competitive level are
better at making a quick judgment call
and the right judgement call when they
have to and that's because once again
it's said specific adaptation to imposed
a man's they are practicing being in a
firefight and even though it's virtual
the brain doesn't know that and you're
still deciding which target is the most
important to shoot first you're still
better at scouting for potential enemies
on the horizon in fact these studies
also show that computed game for game
players have greater visual acuity
they're better at differentiating
between shades of grey so in other words
they can also see the targets on the
horizon better as well so in short you
need to be able to practice in some way
being in a situation where you're using
your senses where you're reacting and
making decisions and computer games is
one of the best ways to do that and as
I've said on this channel before I
recommend using virtual reality would
take that one step further because now
you're completely immersed using all
your senses and your limbs so play some
superhot on oculus rift or some Robo
recall and that could help you survive
the zombie apocalypse next time someone
tells you off for playing to you many
computer games you just point out that
it's helping you to survive the zombie
apocalypse when that happens they'll be
sorry and you'll be laughing unless
there's someone you love in which cases
they're being eaten you'll be crying
watch those videos on flow States day
because I did give some more tips things
such as wide-angle vision for spotting
enemies on the horizon and such as box
breathing which is a technique you can
use to calm yourself down and stay
focused even when you're stressed and in
a life-or-death situation so to
summarize I think that the best zombie
survival training would incorporate long
distance running and fast running so
high-intensity interval training with
calisthenics bodyweight training parkour
rock climbing potentially all these
things you can do in a single training
regime without too much trouble I manage
something similar at the same time
wouldn't hurt to condition your knuckles
and your fists to throw in some martial
arts definitely or at least heavy bag
work and to train with some big lifts to
build up more strength but without being
whilst being mindful
bad too much bulk etc Owen as I've said
before in previous videos this is also
why I really like the idea of having a
day or half a workout set aside for
skills skills training being things like
grip strength or ambidexterity training
or enhancing your senses for instance or
increasing your awareness all the kinds
of stuff that sounds really awesome that
you mean to get into your training
toughening your knuckles increasing
flexibility all that stuff that could
potentially save your ass in these sorts
of situations but that doesn't easily
fit into a regular workout all the stuff
that Batman might have in his arsenal
I'm not gonna go into that into the etl
here because I want to do a video in
future on the skills training workout so
stay tuned for that but as I said at the
start of this video this is any one
scenario so what happens if out like I
say it's Waterworld in which case all
the swimmers will survive so really want
to be as cross-modal as possible and
also zombie apocalypse probably isn't
the most likely thing to happen to you
there are other scenarios where strength
can be very useful such as moving house
and ready for anything training means
being ready for those things too and of
course there are real survival skill in
a zombie apocalypse is teamwork it's
sticking together and we all know that
the person who goes off on their own is
the one that gets eaten first so that
means that really the best thing to do
is to have a range of skills a range of
specialized skills in a group of people
so that's why I'm saying that every kind
of training has its benefits and we all
have our own genetic predisposition we
all have certain types body types that
we start out with so the ectomorph isn't
necessarily going to be very useful when
it comes to moving the rubble that has
trapped you in the bunker but they might
be good for running long distance and
going on you know
fetching the food so yeah send the
skinny guy out to fetch the food
likewise having the tank the big bulky
guy to carry the heavy artillery he's
gonna be useful too that would be the
best scenario to have one of each person
the tracker for getting up onto high
ground and looking out for danger ahead
and the martial artist but
fighting the first wave of attackers
when they break down the door and doing
that heroic sacrifice so yeah it's a bit
like an RPG a computer game where at the
beginning you get to choose your type
and you have some attributes that you're
already slightly stronger in and it
might be but for you the best thing to
do is to focus on those attributes and
become the best version of that that you
can be whether that's the powerful tank
or the long distance runner for most of
us we're more Jack's of all trades we
tend to be metamorph you know average is
more common by definition so for most of
us it makes sense to pick and choose a
few different training modalities yeah
give jambe apocalypse training or ready
for anything training a go and let me
know if you like the sounds of that in
the comments down below let me know what
you agree with and disagree with in this
video let me know what you think the
best form of training would be to
survive some kind of situation like this
and yeah thanks a ton for watching I
really appreciate it if you did enjoy
this video then please leave a like
please share it around that helps me out
massively you can follow me on social
media where you can get more information
on on the brand you know what I'm doing
you can see my workouts you can find out
first when I post new videos etc and of
course check out the full website the
blog over at the bio near comm there'll
be a version of this posted there either
now or soon and that goes into even more
detail so if you want the full story
then you need to follow me on all of the
different forms of media and like I said
I massively appreciate it it helps me
out a huge amount and I love talking to
you guys down there
you've always got loads of really
interesting to say and you're giving me
tons of ideas for future videos so yeah
thanks a ton and I'll see you next time
bye for now
you
one final consideration is that it's not
just important to be well-trained Blatz
to be ready in the moment that means for
instance that you kind of just done a
massive legs day because then it's
difficult to walk let alone run and
fight you want to be wearing the right
clothes if you're wearing smart dress
shoes and restrictive trousers you're
not gonna be able to move around as
freely and you can't be completely
wasted after a long bender can you
imagine if no Ultron attacked and all
the Avengers have just been on a pub
crawl could happen with Tony Stark but
you get the point so I'm not saying that
you can't have fun but you've got to
keep your wits about you like a scout
I actually was attacked once not by
aliens or zombies but by real people
didn't go so well for me I was punched
eight times in the face that's actually
how I got these scars some people have
asked on previous videos part of the
reason for that was that I was
outnumbered and jumped part of the
reason was that I was very drunk on a
night out and thought it was a great
plan to stand there making jigs not
fighting back or running away so point
is that if you want to be truly ready
for anything you need to be a big
tactical you need to keep your wits
about you not getting to paralytic wear
trainers maybe because that way you can
break into a run if necessary I'm a bit
unusual but I always like wearing
trainers so I can turn any trip into a
jog perhaps where flexible fabric denim
that's what I'm in right now of course
that is if you're completely dedicated
to being ready for a zombie apocalypse
which yeah not everyone sees as a
priority